anthony cas ci avait 18 ans dans la nuit
du 5 au 6 novembre 2015
il s'est donné la mort dans la maison
familiale de cinq en haute saône
très vite ophélie sa soeur va faire le
lien avec les réseaux sociaux et surtout
avec un faux profil celui d'une jeune
femme qui venait de contacter son frère
une conversation c'est commencer entre
deux jeunes et au bout du troisième jour
donc des conversations au late 2 octobre
il ya eu des menaces de des demandes
d'argent en échange de vidéos
c'était censé être une jeune femme de
dijon des alentours en fait
et au final baisse mettaient des
harceleurs de côte d'ivoire
ophélie va faire une découverte
surprenante début 2016
la fameuse coiffeuse de dijon qui
conversait avec son frère est un homme
il vit qu'on côte d'ivoire une enquête
que la jeune femme a réalisé seul en se
servant des adresses qui avait contacté
son frère en continuant tout ça il
fallait que je leur envoie de l'argent
pour qu'ils viennent en chose que je
n'ai pas fait évidemment mais du coup ça
m'a permis d'avoir un numéro de
téléphone ça m'a permis d'avoir des
adresses des noms ces hommes sont connus
de la justice française on les appelle
des brouteurs de la cyber criminalité
organisée qui se cache à des milliers de
kilomètres de la france
la difficulté que nous avons que
rencontrent nos enquêteurs imaginer ici
les enquêteurs de haute saône
c'est de pouvoir remonter en termes de
traçabilité effectivement sur des
adresses ip qui se retrouvent dans ces
pays et dans ces pays ça signifie
effectivement à travers l'ambassade ce
qui a été fait ici essayer de localiser
la personne pour répondre à ce phénomène
a été créé dans les groupements de
gendarmerie le sol qu section
opérationnelle de la lutte contre les
cyber menaces depuis donc début d'année
en tout cas en haute saône
on dispose d'une équipe donc de six
personnels qui sont tous formés donc à
faire de la veille numérique
une fois par an minimum dans l'ue
organise des sessions pour former
justement mes camarades sur le terrain à
tout ce qui est sensibilisation au monde
numérique
un mandat d'arrêt international a été
lancé contre le maître chanteur présumés
absent à la barre il sera jugé par
contumace